[Music]
an anti addiction news submitted by
ignorance is bliss oh yeah oh man hooked
on opioids gets a pacemaker implanted in
his brain to treat his addiction oh [ __ ]
a pacemaker pacemaker like aren't those
for hearts yeah why can't they put them
into dicks that aren't working too if it
just was a cure-all for everything else
this is called this treatment it's
called deep brain stimulation how
wonderful and it has been used it's been
used for movement disorders like
Parkinson's but then now the first
medical trial of DBS deep brain
stimulation for methamphetamine
addiction is being conducted in Shanghai
I don't know there was Chinese tweakers
yeah damn meth is all over the world if
hope yours is everywhere bro you know
that's the number one killer for
Caucasians mm-hmm yeah opioid
painkillers so I just numbs you
prescription drugs kills so many [ __ ]
people's over the oh dude oh it's like I
don't want to say the wrong number but I
think it's like 300,000 a year it's a or
like it's [ __ ] tons of people I thought
that number one killer for Caucasians
was [ __ ] wild animals [ __ ] girls
and [ __ ] I'm with you brother I try to
generate now try to get a selfie with a
lion at the zoo and [ __ ] the lines
Allrecipes Crocodile Hunter that's for
sure
it's like that right that's where we're
really close with the Asians to say we
liked we both like to take pictures
dangerous producer family yeah we're
thinking we're just taking pictures of
our food but then you guys are like oh
[ __ ] I'm gonna live on the wild side yep
then we're taking prisoners with
dolphins in the taking you guys are
taking them out of the pen yeah and then
the Mexicans over here we're just like
[ __ ] infant
go for it I just googled it leading
cause of deaths in males and Sapphire in
Caucasians is [ __ ] a lot of animals
probably poor dances like dirt bike we
[ __ ] do it stupid flips come on like
heart disease and like come on
well number one is heart disease number
two is cancer number three is
unintentional injuries number four is
chronic lower respiratory I think it's
out of substance abuse so it's not like
there's no like not like alcohol health
condition yeah it's not of substance
abuse yeah cuz they were showing how
like this graph of like the war on drugs
right like how many people died off of
life cocaine or whatever and then they
show like this drastically huge
difference on like opioids it's like
it's like this much versus like this
menu and fat and all - as part of that -
oh yeah cuz they laced that [ __ ] into a
lot of the opioid drugs that people take
that's crazy man
yeah that's like the new plague then
right Oh a drug drug addiction you know
like needs your balance itself mm-hmm
that's like the new one oh yeah it's the
natural current so that it's correcting
the fact that is wiping out a lot of
people no but it's it's kind of a good
thing anyway so yeah this patient now
thing implanted in his brain so I don't
know what I'm looking at but these are
it's a brace scans of his brain maybe
that thing right there
where's the triangle the triangle right
beneath the orange yep you know what
blows my mind
Green they can read your brain activity
without even like from the outside
like oh yeah we just send out [ __ ]
signals isn't that crazy
that is crazy what are no vibrations and
[ __ ] so you believe in vibes like good
but who doesn't believe in vibes you got
a cool life who amongst us will admit to
not believe in Barb's who does not
belong I believe in Bobby vibes and I
believe in vibes some people call it
mana some people call it Chi this from
people come on
yeah the Hawaiians are the Polynesian oh
that's what's so funny to me when
stand-ups [ __ ] all over people who do
like who do energy stuff and stuff
because I'm always like wait a minute
don't you come off the stage like all
the energy was so good tonight or
they're like um all that room was dead
already when I came into it it's like
wait that doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
if you don't believe in energy and [ __ ]
you better say that [ __ ] if you're
married and Nicky were you but dude it's
real though I mean when you feel room
and you're like the room was already
warmed up for you and then you go up on
stage and it's way easier and could feel
it yeah you just feel that [ __ ] yeah
what Tesla called it he called it ether
do get up on stage so really in a total
really offensive joke to an audience
that's not ready for that and you feel
it in the room don't just do that sting
that [ __ ] feel the same [ __ ] to me
how do you know it's not you that's like
your own mind well no no but it's an N
it's like it's like a reaction that's
all I'm saying or like when you walk
into it doesn't even have to be a stage
you just walk into a room and like you
already know if like someone's been
fighting or if it's like it's positive
or like if they're judging you like you
feel it if I smell something bad that's
bad energy how about we all just watch
the movie and we all it's a sad movie we
all walk out feeling sad I'm saying it's
the same kind of [ __ ] we watch an action
movie you're like yeah that was the flow
you feel the flow you feel the room you
feel it it usually comes out and spills
out in art or things like that so that's
why I always live on a standard flow or
something and someone's like yeah
they're like yeah I'm a cup of corn I'm
like oh yeah you're an idiot river and
I'm like okay dude but like you
literally just got the stage 90 like man
the crowds really really feeling vibes
same [ __ ] to me
same [ __ ] me and equally you could make
fun of both make fun of everything but I
just find it fun
so they're talking about this guy here
who got his deep brain stimulation
pacemaker surgery my hazy dude yeah so
there he was just talking about how for
him his whole life has been ruined
because of his addiction he was first
introduced to meth right after the birth
of his son that's all Oh time again
thought on meth but it wasn't
hotel room right after the birth like
let's celebrate with this pipe so his
friends told him just do it once you've
had your kid you won't have problems and
so smoking made him feel faint and
slightly unhinged and then later he
found that meth brats focus to his mind
so he directed that at one thing which
was cards so every time he smoked he
would gamble and every time he Gamble's
he lost all around totaling around a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars he
started using drugs so his wife divorced
him and he rarely saw his son he took
more drugs so then he checked into a
hospital for detox and then moved to
another town to get away from his bad
influences and he also took Chinese
traditional medicine but then he would
relapse every time is he Chinese because
it sounds like any old math story no
matter where you are in the world that's
what we're all connected bring a couple
you're taught a battle method ginseng
though yeah it's constant losing battle
they said that his willpower was very
weak so then um his friend had undergone
a DBS surgery and so his father gave him
an ultimatum like his father's friend
had the surgery and so his father said
go back to rehab or do brain surgery and
so he chose brain surgery because he's
saying that with the surgery he'll
definitely have a chance to get his life
back what does it do like stimulate the
same reward center that leg or poised
well that's the controversial thing
about is that they don't it's so
experimental right now you don't really
know like exactly where does that and so
people are kind of saying like that's
not yeah the hard part is is filling of
the void when you're dealing with
addiction it's like how do you fill that
void and that high because what most
people do is chase that high whether
addicted to gambling or anything and
then it's difficult to replace it it's
crazy because before these brain
implants started in China those brain
lesion me what is it like a lobotomy
they just cut out pieces of your brain
scoop out pieces of your brain
diction see if it worked to see if it
worked and then it left patients with
mood disorders lost memories and altered
sex drives yeah yeah and he gave the
Scientologists a ton of propaganda
because they [ __ ] hate psychiatry and
all and all that [ __ ] they have a whole
museum I mean this is old psychiatry
yeah in 2004 Oh cuz in an America
lobotomy stopped like ages ago twenties
or thirties or she was talking about
China China's Ministry of Health ordered
a halt for addiction most hospitals in
2004 why did they just read our [ __ ]
history paperwork because they're like
maybe they didn't do the calculations
right that's great or me [ __ ] in Germany
on the [ __ ] Jewish they block the
information right so what if they got
are really late and then they got our
textbook from 1950 maybe they got it in
2004 they're like oh [ __ ] okay we'll
stop all this sauce yeah so they're
saying that DBS devices can cost less
than $25,000 in China and many patients
paid cash and the surgeon said that you
can rest assured for the safety of this
operation there's no problem you will
stop being an addict
what are you doing they like shake your
head and like a big ass oh wow you do
shave they don't cut they drill small
holes and then they feed electrodes deep
into the brain there's something sucking
out of your brain or is it I mean out of
your skull or is it inside yours not the
net [ __ ] man
yeah he's got a cat elope net on his
head yeah does it work yeah I don't
really like meth anymore you may or may
not know this but what does it do like
because it's the reward I'm assuming
that's the reward part of the brain so
once it's craving that reward again does
it do some sort of electronic
stimulation yeah and he's like okay cool
got my fix
yeah oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] gonna hit the button all day
this one's hard for me to like really
wrap my brain around because it's just
scientific as [ __ ] but then the other
side of it is like well is he really
working on the addiction cuz then it's
it's just kind of sweeping it under the
rug
that's like placing about something else
a few days after surgery the doctor
switched on the DBS device and then as
the electrodes were activated he felt a
surge of excitements and the current
running through his body kept him awake
and he said that he spent the whole
night thinking about drugs
the doctor who made a worse they made
him learn how to make drugs in his new
kitchen there's a passion for drugs
mouths yeah so the doctor used this
tablet to adjust the machine inside his
head and so he was like cheerful and
then the patient was a yes and then he
dr. change the settings he's like now
and then he said agitated he said that
he felt heat in his chest and then a
beating sensation numbness and fatigue
and he began to sweat so then the doctor
made a few more modifications he's like
any feelings now he's like yeah I came
[Laughter]
Jesus feels like after some more
modifications he's like any feeling
tones again pretty happy now so he says
that the machine is pretty magical he
adjusted to make you happy and you're
happy to make you nervous and you're
nervous and I stayed like controls your
happiness anger grief and joy and so he
left the hospital the next day more than
six months later he said that he's still
up drugs Oh six months later that's not
bad but he's just extra happy I mean
that's cold turkey almost yeah that's
six months is a lot for an addict
specially for math Bravo did they ever
remove it or he just it's a life thing
well he said that sometimes in his new
life he touches the hard cable in his
neck that leads from the battery pack to
the electrodes in his brain and he
wonders what is this machine doing his
head that's wild
can he go swimming no was actually gonna
like fries brain cells that is wild
that's crazy
some Robo man [ __ ] yeah I'm into it if
it helps the guy I'm into it if it gives
them better quality life it's no
different than the patch I'm about
teaching a man how to fish you know what
I mean yeah what if he keeps failing in
and he goes hungry and dies cuz he did
do it like we have and stuff maybe but
maybe there's just not the right method
yet you know what if while he's fishing
he destroys his life yeah yeah yeah I
mean I get what you're saying but I'm
that I would prefer to have it that way
whereas this one it's like he's kind of
like this controlled like robot like
it's weird you know like we don't know
how that's gonna bleed and affect the
rest of his life I would rather have him
do that then steal for meth and gamble
away yeah absolutely
but Gio would obviously rather have him
steal for Methos what she's saying is
that what I'm saying no I'm but exactly
you're not saying that like to conclude
this guy's story
he is saying that he stayed off drugs
his skin cleared up you put on 20 pounds
when his friends got back in touch he
refused her drugs he tried to rekindle
his relationship with his ex-wife good
job but she was pregnant with her new
husband's child and then he took her to
the got her the procedure and now she's
happy and they're together
she said it's the only shame is that you
came too late oh damn it those type of
movies that Casey likes
yeah yeah he's like actually I just came
right now and I just came again I don't
even need you anymore he's like look at
me I'm [ __ ] blown over here good for
that guy actually give her extra extra
pair of trousers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]